und die bilder die wir ihnen jetzt
zeigen die sind wirklich fürchterlich
wir sehen vom drogenkonsum gezeichnete
gesichter ein mann der sich eine nadel
setzt zählte mit unrat blockieren die
bürgersteige es sind bilder aus portland
die mehr an einen horrorfilm erinnern
die größte metropole des us
bundesstaates oregon ist eigentlich
bekannt für seine lebenskultur für
bücher clubs oder die kultserie portland
ja jetzt aber versinkt sie im absoluten
drogen chaos und obdachlosigkeit
vom drogenkonsum gezeichnete gesichter
ein mann der sich eine spritze setzt
eine ältere frau mit offenbar schwerer
geistiger erkrankung ihr körper in
wilden zuckungen
zelte mit unrat blockieren die
bürgersteige ein geparktes auto mit
zerbrochene fensterscheibe steht am
straßenrand
downtown portland bietet schockierende
alltags szenen wie aus einem horrorfilm
hier in anton portland sieht man das
ausmaß dieser drogen epidemie die diese
stadt erfasst hat man sieht hier fast
ausschließlich drogensüchtige und
homeless hier hinter mir ist eine
schlange von menschen die sich
angestellt haben bei einer
essensausgabe und wenn man in die
gesichter sieht man wie ausgemergelt sie
sind vom extremen
drogenkonsum der ein riesiges problem
hier ist in dieser stadt sind fast
historische szenen die man hier sieht
menschen die verwirrt und verloren
herumlaufen man sieht hier zählte man
sieht menschen mit verwundungen und
verletzungen wirklich eine schlimme lage
teilweise sogar kinder es ist das alles
ist passiert obwohl die stadt eben
versucht hat mit einer strategie der de
kriminalisierung der drogen hier die
lage zu verbessern und man muss sagen
nach ungefähr zwei jahren wenn man sich
hier um sieht in diesen stadtteil dann
muss man sagen dass dieses experiment
vorerst gescheitert ist der laurel hörst
park war früher eine grüne oase zum
ausspannen dann wurde der ort fast
überrannt von obdachlosen dj browning
anwohnerin und chefin einer der
bürgerbewegung sagt
es ist schwierig wenn menschen angst
haben und sich nicht sicher in ihren
häusern fühlen wenn hier in ein haus
eingebrochen wird dann brechen die diebe
nicht nur ein sie pinkeln auch ins bett
des hausbesitzers oder sie lassen ihre
experimente auf der veranda liegen die
bestohlen haben also nicht nur den
verlust ihrer wertgegenstände zu
beklagen oder die angst um ihr leben wir
fühlen uns als hätten wir eine
zielscheibe auf dem rücken aber wir
haben nichts böses getan um so etwas zu
verdienen und es gibt auch keine
möglichkeit das zu ändern
mike marshall geschäftsführer der
organisation origin rica will sagt es
fehlt an zentralen stellen die die
richtigen prioritäten setzen
unser nächster gouverneur muss sagen
dieses problem müssen wir zuerst angehen
und dafür setze ich folgende personen
ein diese person hat dann vier behörden
unter sich und der held koordiniertes
feedback genauso wie in europa wo alle
länder zusammengekommen sind um die
ukraine gegen russland zu unterstützen
so muss es auch bei uns in portland sein
dass alle zusammen kommen um gegen die
drogenabhängigkeit zu kämpfen aber das
haben wir momentan nicht wir haben
unabhängige organisationen die nicht
miteinander reden und eine gouverneurin
die sie nicht zur rechenschaft zieht so
macht jeder was er will und nichts wird
er erreicht bild erlebt beim besuch in
der 600 50.000 einwohner stadt ein
irrenhaus unter freiem himmel fast alle
menschen auf der straße sind hier
obdachlos und süchtig der großteil der
geschäfte sind geschlossen einwohner und
kunden fehlanzeige außer kontrolle
wirken auch die verbrechensraten in
portland mit 90 morgen wurde im vorjahr
ein trauriger rekord verzeichnet